this is your first movie with heartbeat
production how did you know when it was
fired you and Tiffany get together how
did you know the moment that it was like
you're like oh my god we got some
special you know what day one all said
the energy everybody showed up everybody
was excited from Tiffany for myself from
the rest of the cast our director
Malcolm Lee our crew everybody showed up
with the energy that said you know what
we're happy about the project that we
signed up to do we think it's funny but
we're ready to elevate we're ready to
take our game to the next level and
raise the material and that's exactly
what they did and from a producing
standpoint that's what you want well and
by the way I heard you might even get a
tear or two out of folks is this gonna
be off it's gonna be like that it's a
movie with a message I think if I'm
gonna be known for anything especially
in a producing world I want to be known
for creating movies with not only a
message but that are relatable if you
get identified with and you know put
themselves in certain situations and I
think this is it this is the kind of
content that I want to be a definition
of my company and of my brand and to
date this is my only one that I can put
my company name on and I threw
everything in this basket and I'm hoping
that people respond so I can get more OC
nice cool go tonight school doesn't get
better than that
all right and by the way my dad is gonna
be so excited about that suit Wow love
your dad mine but you remind me of them
right now
what are these pockets for okay have
news for like ID if you're a tourist you
don't want to get robbed they can steal
your stuff
that's like smart and it's like you're
just everything rain tennis track yeah
you got it all comfort yeah age is about
comfort good for you cat thanks guys man
thanks man yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
you